A LOT PRESCRIPTION PILLS POLICE
HAVE BEEN CRACKING DOWN ON
THOSE.
YOU CAN FIND IT IN ANY SIZED
CITY.
>> Reporter: IT'S BROAD DAYLIGHT
IN PHILADELPHIA.
SO IT'S PLAIN TO SEE THIS HEROIN
DEAL IN THE MAKING.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT JUST LEFT, THEY'RE
ALL ADDICTS.
SO THEY'RE IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
HERE.
THEY'RE LOOKING TO GET THEIR FIX
FOR THE DAY.
N
NOT.
>> Reporter: NOT JUST ON THIS
CORNER.
AS A DEA AGENT DROVE US AROUND,
WE SAW DEALERS AND ADDICTS AT
NEARLY EVERY INTERSECTION.
HE SHOWED ME THE TINY BAGS THE
HEROIN IS SOLD IN, UNDER STREET
NAMES LIKE BUD ICE, WHITE HOUSE,
EVEN DEA.
AND THE BUYERS?
ANYONE FROM HIGH SCHOOLERS TO
HOUSEWIVES.
HE SAYS MOST OF THE HEROIN HERE
IS COMING FROM MEXICAN CARTELS.
IT'S A CHEAP FIX.
JUST $10 A BAG.
AND SO EASY TO GET.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
THE DEALERS HAVE GUYS ON THE
STREET THEY CALL LOOK OUTS.
>> ONCE A BUYER WALKS DOWN THE
STREET, YOU'LL HAVE THOSE
LOOKOUTS DIRECT THEM, HEY,
THEY'RE ON THE CORNER OF 6th AND
MARSHALL.
>> Reporter: LOOKOUTS AREN'T
JUST FOR BUYERS BUT POLICE, TOO.
SOME ARE IN CARS.
HONKING THEIR HORNS TO ALERT THE
DEALERS.
WATCH WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE SHOW
UP.
>> AS YOU CAN SEE, PEOPLE
WALKING AWAY.
THIS RIGHT HERE ARE SEVERAL DRUG
DEALERS ON THE CORNER.
>> THEY'RE ON THE MOVE.
>> THEY'RE MOVING.
YOU SEE THIS GUY MOVING?
YOU SEE THESE GUYS MOVING DOWN
THE ROAD HERE?
ALL RIGHT.
WE GOT A LOOKOUT.
THIS INDIVIDUAL HERE PROBABLY IS
LOOKING TO CUP BAGS OF HEROIN.
>> THOSE GUYS JUST RAN
BASICALLY.
>> THEY'RE RUNNING.
THEY KNOW WE'RE HERE.
>> Reporter: THE AGENT SAYS
PENNSYLVANIA HEROIN IS THE
PUREST EAST OF THE MISSISSIPPI.
BUT THAT STILL HASN'T STOPPED
SOME DEALERS FROM MIXING IT WITH
DRUGS LIKE FENTANYL, A POWERFUL
NARCOTIC OFTEN USED TO TREAT
CANCER PATIENTS.
JUST LAST MONTH, 22 PEOPLE DIED
FROM HEROIN OVERDOSES IN WESTERN
PENNSYLVANIA.
ALL OF IT HAD BEEN LACED WITH
FENTANYL.
>> FENTANYL IS EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS.
EXTREMELY POTENT.
AND TWO TO THREE GRAINS OF SALT
JUST TO PUT ANYTIME PERSPECTIVE,
OFTEN TAN ILL MIXED IN WITH
HEROIN COULD KILL A SEASONED
HEROIN ADDICT.
>> THEY DON'T TELL YOU IT'S IN
THERE.
>> Reporter: THE AGENT'S TEAM
RECENTLY SEIZED OVER 12 KILO
GRAMS OF HEROIN WORTH MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ON THE STREET.
THESE ARE EVIDENCE PHOTOS OF
JUST SOME OF THE HEROIN AND
WEAPONS THEY'VE PICKED UP.
BUT DEALERS ARE GOING TO
EXTREMES.
LIKE THIS ONE, WOMAN POLICE SAY,
WHO WAS SELLING HEROIN IN
McDONALD'S HAPPY MEALS.
$2 FOR THE TOY, 80 BUCKS FOR THE
HEROIN.
THOSE EXTREMES AND CREATIVITY
ARE ONLY MAKING HIS JOB HARDER.
>> SOMETIMES THEY'LL HAVE SMALL
AMOUNTS ON THEM.
AND SOMETIMES IT WILL BE HIDDEN.
IT WILL BE HIDDEN IN THAT
MAILBOX.
COULD BE HIDDEN UNDERNEATH THE
CAR.
IT WILL BE HIDDEN IN A CORNER.
THEN THEY'LL GO AND RE UP THE
AMOUNT THAT THEY HAVE ON THEM.
SO THEY NEVER TAKE A CHANCE TO
LOSE THEIR PRODUCT.
>> RANDI JOINS US LIVE.
RANDI, AMAZING TO SEE HOW OPEN
IT IS.
WHY DON'T THEY PICK THESE GUYS
UP THAT YOU SAW SELLING ON THE
STREETS?
WHY NOT PICK THEM UP?
>> Reporter: THAT'S WHAT I
ASKED, TOO.
BECAUSE THEY ARE OUT THERE DOING
IT RIGHT THERE IN THE OPEN.
SO I SAID WHY AREN'T THE POLICE
HERE?
WHY AREN'T THESE GUYS BEING
ARRESTED?
AND REALLY, ANDERSON, THOSE
AREN'T THE GUYS THEY WANT.
THEY WANT THE BIG GUYS, THE GUYS
WHO ARE RUNNING THIS
ORGANIZATION.
I'M TOLD THEY CAN BRING IN AS
MUCH AS $100,000, ANDERSON, IN A
SINGLE SHIFT OF ABOUT EIGHT
HOURS.
BUT THE GUYS ON THE STREET WHO
ARE RISKING ARREST OUT THERE,
THEY ONLY GET A COUPLE HUNDRED
DOLLARS, MAYBE $300 I'M TOLD.
IT'S THE BIG GUYS WHO ARE RAKING
IN AND CASHING IN ON THESE WHOLE
DEAL.
>> SO THE ONES SELLING ON THE
STREET ARE JUST LOW-LEVEL MIDDLE
MEN.
>> Reporter: EXACTLY.
THEY'RE HARDLY MAKING ANY MONEY.
A COUPLE, $300 FOR AN EIGHT-HOUR
SHIFT.
MAYBE THAT'S GOOD MONEY TO THEM.
BUT THE GUYS WHO ARE REALLY
BRINGING IT IN ARE THE ONES
PULLING IN $100,000 EVERY DAY,
EVERY EIGHT HOURS.
>> YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO APPROACH
ANY OF THESE ACTUAL DEALERS,
WERE YOU?
>> NO.
I MEAN, IN FACT OUR SPECIAL
AGENT THAT WE WERE WITH HE HAD
HIS WEAPON OUT.
IT WAS A PRETTY DICEY SCENE.
BUT I DID ASK HIM, I WANT TO SEE
HOW EASY IT IS.
CAN I GO UP TO ONE OF THESE GUYS
OR GROUPS TO TRY TO BUY SOME OF
THIS.
NO MAINLY HE WOULDN'T LET ME
IT'S ILLEGAL.
BUT ALSO HE SAID IT'S SO RISKY.
IF I HAD GONE THERE ON MY OWN TO
TRY TO BUY SOME HEROIN LIKE SOME
OF THESE HIGH SCHOOLERS, HIGH
SCHOOL WRESTLERS COMING,
HOUSEWIVES COMING.
IF I WAS DOING THAT HE SAID NOT
ONLY WOULD I RISK BEING DRAGGED
INTO AALLY AND BEING ABUSED BUT
I WOULD ALSO RISK